regardez
il est 19h30 jeudi soir quand toutes les
chaînes de télévision suspendent
subitement leur programme je vous
interromps la reine Elizabeth II n'est
plus de ce monde elle est décédée la
reine Elizabeth II est décédée cet
après-midi à 96 ans et après 70 ans de
règne la reine Élisabeth devient de
rendre son dernier souffle le drapeau de
Buckingham
m Palace
va alors se mettre en place dans les
prochains jours
qui signifie le pont de Londres et
tomber au Royaume-Uni devant le palais
de Buckingham des milliers de personnes
sont venus pleurer le décès de leur
souveraine
la première ministre britannique
listtreuse a pris la parole quelques
heures après l'annonce pour saluer
Charles III le nouveau roi d'Angleterre
aujourd'hui la couronne passe comme elle
l'a fait pendant plus de 1000 ans à
notre nouveau monarque notre nouveau
chef d'État Sa Majesté le roi Charles
III et c'est à travers toute la planète
que de nombreux hommages lui sont rendus
depuis jeudi soir aussi bien de la part
des dirigeants politiques
[Musique]
Queen the second c'est avec une grande
tristesse que nous apprenons aujourd'hui
du décès de sa Majesté la reine
Élisabeth II que de personnalités
publiques comme Elton John qui était en
concert à Toronto
toujours de deuil ont été proclamés
jusqu'au funérailles de la reine qui
auront lieu à l'abbaye de Westminster
Elisabeth II restera à jamais une icône
de la monarchie britannique
[Musique]
nous rejoins Deckers qui a les yeux ici
le pauvre depuis hier il enseigne
matinale et sur toutes les scènes
d'infos merci Bertrand et puis Guillaume
frisquet que vous connaissez si vous
regardez l'émission il était avec nous
pendant très longtemps et il a quitté
l'émission non pas parce qu'on a viré
parce que c'est lui qui est producteur
et qui voulait faire d'autres choses et
tu crois bien qu'on te regrette
Guillaume dans l'émission merci tu es
fan de la manger britannique tu connais
très bien tu as fait beaucoup beaucoup
de documentaires pour saga pour TF1 pour
nous et je l'ai rencontré et tu l'as
rencontré en plus voilà donc c'est dire
donc tout a commencé hier je dis à
13h30-4 quand voilà comme les quêtes
Buckingham relève que les médecins
d'aren sont très préoccupés donc ça déjà
à ce moment-là qu'est-ce qui se passe
Guillaume à 13h34 quand est-ce
communiquer qu'est-ce qui se passe dans
le monde alors en fait au moment où les
médecins commencent à dire que la reine
ne va pas bien et qu'il officialise
c'est que elle va partir pas bien du
tout du tout du tout d'aucun 10 même que
elle serait déjà morte d'accord et qu'on
ne pouvait pas annoncer d'abord en
Angleterre on annonce jamais la mort
d'un roi après midi parce que ça veut
dire que ce serait dans les journaux du
soir et ça peut être dans un journal du
soir dans le monde moi-même dans le
monde à ce moment-là ça a été un
retentissement à peu près dans le monde
je crois 197 pays
150 pays homo dans le monde il y en a
156 qu'on cassé leur antenne pour être
en direct non-stop c'est l'info que j'ai
entendu
effectivement tous à la radio que juste
elle n'allait pas très bien
80% des pays dans le monde ont fait un
breaking news est-ce que c'est pas
incroyable oui parce que c'est la
dernière icône en fait ça fait un peu de
phrase de vieux tu vois tu vas me
comprendre en fait hier on a
définitivement tourné la page du 20e
siècle plus il y aura plus jamais ça
pour pour quelqu'un jamais ça n'existera
plus là depuis on est donc samedi soir
depuis jeudi après-midi c'est non-stop
dans le monde entier tout le monde est
devant sa télé et même si on l'aime pas
beaucoup on s'en un peu tout le monde
sait qui elle est tout le monde sait qui
est la troisième question est-ce que
c'est vrai ce qui se dit qu'à 13h34
quand ils disent qu'elle est très
souffrante elle est déjà morte il
semblerait que d'après les informations
qui nous reviennent des millions
informés ce serait plutôt survenu vers
16h vers 16h c'est voilà et alors on
rappelle que elle était entourée de
Charles de Camila et de Williams on est
certain ils étaient à son chevet et en
revanche et bien les autres enfants vont
arriver plus tard à savoir le prince
hundrew le prince Edward la princesse
voilà jusqu'à la elle a quatre enfants
et Harry sera le tout dernier bien sûr
la BBC donc interrompre ses programmes
regardez
vient d'annoncer la mort de la reine Sa
Majesté Elizabeth II
dans son communiqué le palais dit
qu'elle est partie en paix à balmorrow
cet après-midi baby la BBC enregistre ce
programme spécial en l'honneur de la
reine Sa Majesté Elizabeth II
oui oui Guillaume vous savez que quand
vous êtes journaliste à la BBC vous
devez forcément avoir un costume noir
toujours sur vous pour que si quelqu'un
de la monarchie meurt vous puissiez vous
mettre en noir et moins les
correspondants que j'avais eu en
Angleterre m'ont dit si les journalistes
de la BBC se mettent en noir c'est qu'en
fait ils vont annoncer dans peu de temps
qu'elle est morte et ça n'a pas loupé
quand il annonce il est déjà en noir
donc on a su avant qu'elle était déjà
mortes absolument évident s'il y a eu
des premiers signes avant-coureurs qui
nous ont été donnés on a vu des
barrières métalliques qui ont commencé à
être dressés on a demandé aux personnes
qui visitaient les résidences royales de
sortir aux visiteurs donc c'était pour
nous déjà des signes tangibles que le la
Little bridge code était lancée mais
Bertrand comment tu expliques deux jours
avant on l'a vu serrer la main de la
nouvelle Première ministre qui elle
avait l'air plus d'enfants
le mercredi même si c'est pas officiel
les bruits quand même nous disent que il
y aurait eu un accident vasculaire
cérébral qui aurait eu lieu le mercredi
cette photo-là est prise le mardi on
s'est connu un accident vasculaire
cérébral soit problème de sang
ça serait déjà voilà le premier signe
dans des règlements et on peut dire
aussi que son père qu'elle adorait
George VI est décédé en 1952 du combos
et c'est exactement la même chose on
peut mais en tout cas si c'est le cas
c'est une mort qui est assez enfin
j'imagine assez douce et assez rapide il
y avait un auteur que je citais à
Guillaume cet après-midi et qui disait
mais je sais plus l'auteur qui disait
les gens extraordinaires ont souvent une
mort ordinaire mais c'est ce qu'on lui
souhaitait qu'elle souffre pas cette
dame deux jours avant ça allait bien et
qu'elle s'est éteinte avec un AVC rapide
c'est tout ce qu'on pouvait lui willium
ce qui est bien c'est que et en fait moi
ce qui m'a mis je vous l'avais dit au
bureau ce qui m'a mis un peu le la puce
à l'oreille c'est que normalement il y a
des images quand elle rencontre par le
ministre il n'y a pas d'image il y a
deux photos il y en a une ou elle toute
seule et cette photo là c'est les seuls
et donc on se dit quand on voit la tâche
qui veut dire en gros qu'elle aurait eu
un cathéter ou quelque chose on l'a
peut-être sorti du lit pomponner parce
qu'elle a vu avant Boris Johnson qui est
venu en Écosse et le bout du monde quoi
c'est perdu dans les montagnes
lointaines il fait froid regardez au
mois de septembre il y a du feu elle est
en pull enfin c'est franchement
et du coup elle était il y a pas il y a
pas d'image donc ce qui veut dire ça se
trouve non elle a pas non mais là il est
allumé mais on l'a peut-être shooter une
question pour tous les deux pourquoi en
ce moment alors moi bêtement je me
disais c'est Buckingham c'est là que ça
se passe pourquoi tout se passe en
Écosse en ce moment bah parce que c'est
mort
lié à la tradition Elisabeth II qu'elle
avait émis ce souhait quand même comme
son père comme son grand-père de ses
tason gringen qui est dans le nordfalk
donc c'était pas prévu du tout ce décès
en fait elle a répété elle-même ses
obsèques vous savez que les obsèques qui
sont préparés depuis des années une fois
par an en voiture elle faisait là il se
passera ça là il se passera ça non
j'aime pas je veux ça sauf que c'était
prévu qu'elle meurt à Buckingham et elle
est morte en Écosse alors quelque part
c'est un joli signe parce que sa mère
était aussi je trouve enfin est-ce pas
fait exprès justement pour pour le
printemps je veux dire d'être là-bas
non mais est-ce qu'elle est pas restée
là-bas par rapport à Édimbourg etc non
parce que la reine elle avait un
planning toute sa vie était très
codifiée l'été c'était Balmoral
d'ailleurs quand Diana est morte elle
était à Balmoral donc en fait pour
William et Harry dès qu'ils vont en
Balmoral il y a un mort il y avait eu
leur mère maintenant il y a leur
grand-mère mais ils avaient envisagé
qu'elle puisse mourir là-bas puisque
l'opération Unicorn c'est quand même
tout un programme qui est déjà envisagé
avant de rapatrier la dépouille mortelle
en train donc l'opération unicornes même
si elle serait morte à une sorte dans le
fond elle aurait eu lieu mais ce qui ce
qui complique un peu la donne c'est que
comme on est dans un autre pays comme on
est en Écosse et ben pour le coup elle
va devoir passer le protocole veut
qu'elle passe par le palais officiel
écossais qui est Hollywood house ça ça
va avoir lieu dimanche et il va y avoir
en première office religieux qui aura
lieu ce lundi en la cathédrale
Saint-Gilles
peut-être moi le premier en fait je suis
un peu perdu parce que il y a Buckingham
je viens d'apprendre qu'à Balmoral en
Écosse qui était un peu sa maison de
campagne
j'entends des des grandes
il y a un gros quatre grands châteaux il
y a Buckingham qui n'est pas à elle
d'accord qu'elle peut pas le vendre mais
c'est la résidence de du lundi au
vendredi d'accord du lundi au jeudi
après il y a oui
qui est à 40 km voilà qui n'est pas elle
non plus et qui est le plus vieux
château habitat d'accord ça Winsor et
Buckingham c'est pas elle pas elle il y
a Balmora la résidence d'été alors
Balmoral il y a 20 000 hectares de terre
il y a des forêt il y a des chevaux il y
a 150 c'est gigantesques
c'est à elle Sandrine Games et à l'aise
d'Angleterre c'est à elle aussi alors ça
c'est il y a ça il y a je crois
78000 m², c'est elle aussi c'est
d'accord donc en fait il y en a quatre
gros deux à l 2 à l'état d'accord très
bien donc écharpe va hériter du magret
si vous voulez on peut peut-être
préciser que Balmoral étant une
propriété privée il y a une propriété
officielle dont j'ai là de vous parler
qui est le palais de Hollywood Hobbs
qu'on connaît très peu d'engrais mais
qui est le siège officiel en Écosse
lorsqu'elle séjourne en Écosse mais
pourquoi vous l'avez déjà rencontré vous
ah parce qu'elle est venue en France en
2004 et je faisais un documentaire
autour de l'ex c'était à l'époque de
Chirac et il y a une il y a eu un une
elle est arrivée à l'Elysée elle vient
en train elle était Alizée alors elle
était toute petite je vais pas serrer la
main mais j'étais à côté d'une personne
à qui elle est serré parce que en fait
quand vous êtes dans une pièce c'est
très impressionnant tout d'un coup tout
d'un coup on vous dit la reine arrive
et à ce moment là il y a des pages qui
rentrent il y a un trône qui arrive il y
a des types avec des étendards enfin il
y a tout un tralala il y a une dame qui
est à côté et vous ne parlez pas la
reine vous n'allez pas voir la reine
c'est la dame qui est à côté qui lui dit
on va aller voir cette personne là la
reine vient alors elle vous dites
ordonnance voilà elle vous dit vous ne
parlez pas c'est à elle de vous parler
alors elle vous dit elle a dit à la
personne à qui j'étais à côté
vous trouvez pas qu'il fait beau
aujourd'hui ah oui aimez-vous
l'Angleterre et hop après vous elle
attend la réponse elle vous regarde mais
quand elle vous regarde en fait elle se
fout de la réponse parce que son métier
c'est à dire que son métier c'est 300
jours par an rencontré des gens à
l'inaugurer des pissotiers
à des gens qui n'ont rien à dire qui ne
l'intéresse pas mais elle doit elle doit
leur poser une question et s'y
intéresser
80 je ne me demandais pas pourquoi les
Gipsy King faisait un concert en
Angleterre devant la reine et j'y étais
et comme je m'étais fait une infection
de la jambe et que je vais le pied dans
le plâtre elle est venue elle est venue
vers moi elle m'a montré et on est venu
me dire que la reine demandait ce que
j'avais eu j'ai une infogite et donc on
est venu me rapporter que j'avais une
inflige elle m'a fait un petit signe
elle est partie c'est incroyable ça mais
c'était une
et après le divine qui est passionné par
la reine incroyable c'est de te dire que
cette dame qui dans le fond a rencontré
toutes les stars les plus grands savants
et tout cela et bah ils se retrouvent
face à des personnes qui ont peur de
leur latin ils ne connaissent plus le
prénom de leurs enfants ils ne savent
plus le nom du village où ils sont nés
et c'est très très régulier alors on me
dit qu'on a extrait de Chirac justement
Chirac et la reine regardez ah oui
Chirac la touche en 2004 Jean-Louis
Debré est président de l'Assemblée
nationale il accompagne Jacques Chirac
lors de son déplacement chez nos voisins
anglais
il se souvient parfaitement être passé à
deux doigts d'un incident diplomatique
se réaliste le cortège officiel a
quelques minutes de retard et
naturellement il arrive ce qui va
arriver c'est que Chirac arrive en
retard
et la reine n'est pas là pour
l'accueillir
je vois Chirac monter l'escalier il m'a
dit ouais Queen
et on lui prévient que comme il est en
retard la reine est reparti dans ses
appartements
[Applaudissements]
en disant de la reine qui va passer
juste derrière cette émission qui est
plein d'anecdotes et il raconte après
jean-lucré dans la on n'a pas pu tout
monter que ensuite il voulait boire de
l'alcool Jacques Chirac mais non
il était à table
forcément la reine part dans ses
appartements ils fonce dans le salon et
à Jean-Louis et maintenant tu amènes la
bière
et je voudrais demander à Guillaume si
elle est vrai cette anecdotes que
racontait Roselyne Bachelot ils sont
dans le carrosse de la reine Jacques
Chirac et elle en 97 ou 98 et il y a un
cheval un des deux chevaux qui tire le
carrosse qui fait un énorme pet et la
reine
je suis désolé et il répond oh c'est pas
grave je croyais que c'était le cheval
je vous avais dit on n'est pas sur
France 2 niveau protocole
moi je sais qu'elle avait pas aimé quand
elle était dans le carrosse avec avec
Chirac parce que Chirac faisait un truc
qu'elle ne fait pas parce que quand on
est déclaré en fait elle est très cool
sauf quand elle est reine quand elle est
pareille avec ses petits-enfants enfin
même si ses petits-enfants arrivaient au
petit déjeuner vous lui faites la
révérence et ils disent ah Majesty c'est
pas ça va m'aimer comment tu vas et donc
Chirac le problème c'est qu'il faisait
comme ça il embrassait la foule et elle
elle trouvait que c'était un peu commun
non hormis un peu comme on dit Boulogne
une ampoule alors Bertrand c'est une
question est-ce qu'on sait maintenant
parce qu'elle est partie avec tous ses
secrets mais est-ce qu'on sait quand
même parmi tous les hommes d'État les
chefs d'État les ministres les ministres
qu'elle a rencontré ce qu'elle aimait ce
qu'elle aimait moins il y en a qu'elle a
pas aimé quand même
absolument Donald Trump oui puisque
alors il y a cette anecdote qui raconte
que le c'est en 2018 en juin 2018 elle
reçoit Donald et Melania Trump alors
déjà elle pèse parce qu'ils arrivent
avec l'hélicoptère d'État il se pose sur
le gazon de Buckingham ils font de gros
trous donc déjà elle
et le soir du dîner de gala qui a lieu
au
Palais de Buckingham donc et bien elle
va décider de porter une parure de rubis
et cette parure de rugby elle est très
symbolique puisque les rubis on le sait
très bien quelqu'un qui connaît un peu
la joaillerie ce sont des pierres qui
ont le pouvoir de de rebuter les forces
du mal elle va ostensiblement pour que
la presse s'en rende compte faire cela
sur son ce petit geste sur son collier
toutes les caméras vont zoomer
automatiquement on va décrypter il
paraît qu'elle n'aimait pas
et François Hollande non voilà jusqu'à
destin c'est pas ça
quand même offert son chien un de ses
chiens pour l'Entente Franco
alors en fait François Hollande je
répète un peu ce que j'entends en fait
elle adorait Mitterrand et d'ailleurs on
dit que Mitterrand et elle était était
cousin à la mode de Bretagne très loin
non c'est pas ça c'est que François
Hollande quand il a reçu les lisait il a
trinqué avec elle il n'a pas bu et même
une gorgée et surtout il s'est assis
tout de suite et normalement on attend
que la reine s'assied et on s'assied et
puis avant jus et juste avant ça il
l'avait laissé peut-être qu'il y avait
un dossier important il a laissé l'arène
pendant 5 minutes toute seule on ne
laisse pas là
la différence entre une république et
une monarchie c'est que en monarchie la
représentation c'est un job à ton plat
voilà
maîtrisait comme personne
mais vous l'avez prédit la semaine
passée quand on a abordé le Oui-Oui
l'amour oui vous en avez pas qu'à moi
vous en avez parlé vous avez dit on lui
souhaite une longue vie on a abordé le
sujet sur les didiana et vous allez dire
à un moment donné qu'on lui souhaite une
longue vie on la sent pas très bien en
ce moment là c'est ça qui est fou quand
j'ai vu ça
j'entends souvent notamment les jeunes
pas toi mais à la reine ça va je la
connaissais pas mais peu importe la mort
de la reine c'est un événement mondial
planétaire on va être à 3 ou 4 milliards
de téléspectateurs pour ses obsèques qui
devraient être lundi téléspectateurs bah
il y en a eu trois pour le mariage de
Diana donc ça va vous montrer quand même
très drôle à vous montrer c'est que
Bertrand Bertrand j'ai un truc que vous
il y a eu des hommages évidemment
hommage d'hommes politiques hommage de
grande soutien et
là je montrerai les images jantes
télé-réalité elle peut compliquer
d'abord on va regarder quelques images
regardez incroyable
vas-y bébé tu lances tu lances tu lances
tu es là tu appuies sur le bouton
appuies avec un sein appuie avec un sein
voilà ah voilà ça c'est Mick Jagger
toute ma vie ça m'a jeté la reine a
toujours été là dans mon enfance bref
c'est très beau c'est Mick Jagger la
grande classe elle adore le rock un
autre alors Elton John évidemment mon
ami il m'en avait parlé il sort
Elton John pardon qui a été voilà et oui
c'est maintenant
c'est plus chiant ça pire
jean-charlançon on commence un petit peu
à chuter un petit peu
exceptionnel elle marque son temps son
pays
alors attention maintenant on passe
c'est plus
candidate de télé-réalité qui a voulu
lui rendre hommage
la vie
non c'est pas possible c'est un même
c'est un même elle s'est expliqué après
en fait elle a vu ça dans une story de
quelqu'un qu'elle suivait elle l'a pris
un screenshot elle l'a partagé sans même
savoir
si 2022 non mais c'est génial il y a une
explication pour dire ah c'était
l'autodérision tu parles tu en as
d'autres aussi je crois télé-réalité tu
en as d'autres
celle-là mais mais c'est vrai que il y a
quelques personnes quelques jeunes
personnes qui ont voulu faire des choses
un peu mignonnes et qui sont trompés de
personnes ils ont tapé vieille dame sur
Internet merde quand même c'est l'humour
au troisième
degrés
attention
perruque je ne pense un peu le contraire
merci à vous merci qui a Cyril pour le
coup mais moi alors pour le coup depuis
jeudi je suis inondée de messages de
très jeune de très jeune téléspectateurs
qui disent et bien on voilà on
s'intéresse à la reine merci on
reconnaît que c'était une grande dame
qui s'en va alors c'est un peu drôle il
me présente leur condoléances comme si
je faisais partie de la famille spéciale
je trouve ça dans le fond très touchant
et de la part de très gentes
téléspectateurs donc on peut dire dans
le fond qu'elle a réussi à toucher tout
le monde bien sûr et la dernière
séquence avec l'ours Paddington pour le
monde entier elle devient une granite
platine alors on a une vraie question on
a une vraie question regardez parce que
regardez on a une image c'est la reine
et ses gorghis pardon ce sont ces chiens
euh il paraît qu'elle aimait les chiens
c'est vrai
son père lui a fait son premier Corgi
quand il était petit elle les a toujours
alors c'est des chiens très méchants
c'est ils sont méchants harnais
agressifs et elle les nourrissait tous
les jours à la viande elle-même dans un
plateau d'argent et d'ailleurs Charles
III le nouveau roi a dit lui-même
qu'elle est chiant il a dit moi les
chiens ça ne sera pas sur des plateaux
d'argent termin je peux te dire c'est
fini le grand genre ils étaient très
méchant les chiens et elle faisait le
test du Premier ministre c'est vrai que
tous les oui alors il paraît justement
c'était le c'était le truc des premiers
ministres un jour il y a un Premier
ministre qui le chien est venu à donner
un petit coup de pied dans le chien
terminé c'est terminé elle voulait plus
elle était obligé de le recevoir mais
elle voulait plus le considérer il avait
tapé ils sont très méchants hein
qu'est-ce qu'ils viennent
et Meghan Markle et bah Meghan Markle va
réussir un peu à amadouer les chiens et
tout de suite les chiens vont voilà
faciliter ce premier contact non il
disait quoi les chiens dans ce cas-là ah
bah là il y a 4 mois les chiens qui sont
sur les tombes des maîtres tu sais qui
dure pendant trois semaines
en fait elle n'en voulait plus parce
qu'elle a dit elle elle voulait plus de
jeunes corghis parce qu'elle en avait
plusieurs elle en voulait plus et les
quatre corps
sont arrivés par hélicoptère hier pour
pouvoir aller saluer la la la la
dépouille de la reine
absolument
des photos je peux vous la montrer
absolument les quatre on a vu la photo
avec les quatre corriers effectivement
dans les je sais pas
en même temps dans le même plateau dans
la même mission le même jour on critique
un mec qui prend les joueurs du PSG
c'est une femme là elle a dépenser un
CO2
et alors écoute mais c'est complètement
à part la reine d'Angleterre c'est
un classeur
je vous donne la parole et l'autre
laissez-moi vous montrer une image parce
qu'évidemment celle-là aussi elle a fait
le tour du monde c'est la reine qui
regarde mal et Dieu sait elle peut
penser à ma grand-mère vous savez les
grands-mères quand elles ont un œil un
peu noir comme ça ça se voit tout de
suite
lors de son mariage regardez voilà ici
voilà on sent qu'ils n'ont pas être
copines c'est pas vrai du tout
spécialiste toi tu as déjà choisi ton
corps Bertrand elle détestait Mégane
mais elle détestait les DJ on le sait
puisqu'elle a même du s'excuser lors des
exclus lors de lors de pardon de
l'enterrement Lady elle a fait à la
télévision elle a dit qu'elle avait été
touchée qu'elle avait mal montré on s'en
souvient est-ce qu'elle détestait les
deux ou est-ce qu'il y en a une des deux
qu'elle détestait plus ah au stade où
cette photo est prise je pense qu'elle
ne déteste pas encore Meghan Markle elle
a cette incroyable ouverture d'esprit
justement au moment du mariage de voir
en Meghan Markle quelqu'un qui va
défendre les minorités au sein même de
la famille royale elle lui laisse
vraiment une chance Mégane marque
que l'on voit là c'est vrai qu'elle a
une tête qui se réjouissait pas non plus
bienvenue sur les femmes et après
Florian et elle aimait beaucoup la
compagnie des hommes elle a toujours été
fidèle contrairement à son mari qui lui
est allé faire il est avant mais elle a
une petite histoire quand même et que
celui qui s'occupait de ses chevaux
regardez mais il a 10 minutes la main
sur la Manche et puis voilà c'est non
non non non non
j'ai pas d'information sur la reine
d'Angleterre et ça c'est sexualité mais
regardez profitez-en parce qu'elle est
morte pour regarder c'est incroyable
série qui s'appelle the crown c'est pas
la vérité
pour le grand public c'est très bien de
dire de regarder The Queen quand même
oui c'est très bien mais c'est
exactement la vérité
alors Florian j'ai une question pour nos
deux spécialistes parce que je discutais
hier avec une journaliste anglaise qui
me disait et qui me parlait d'arrêt
Mégane si on en a beaucoup parlé sur
splato de depuis presque un an elle me
disait qu'en fait la reine faisait un
peu de tampon c'est à dire que la reine
elle a toujours aimé les rebelles donc
elle était très proche d'Harry et que
finalement elle
depuis tout à l'heure
qu'elle est intelligente elle est pas
mal alors c'est vrai qu'on sait on a vu
que Mégane et Harry on rejoint
l'Angleterre le weekend dernier on se
demande d'ailleurs si le médecin leur
avait pas déjà dedans pas du tout
mais il paraît surtout que Harry du coup
qui a pas eu le temps d'y avoir à sa
grand-mère est inconsolable est-ce que
vous avez des infos sur ça je sais pas
s'il est inconsolable mais c'est normal
qu'un petit-fils parce qu'elle était
très proche elle aimait beaucoup Harry
parce que il lui rappelait le mari de la
reine il aimait la même chose il était
un peu il était tellement d'autres
occasions de pouvoir se rendre auprès de
sa grand-mère pour lui dire adieu elle
les avait invités
donc Harry on en a excuse-moi mais un
peu marre aussi
moi j'en ai marre
on rappelle quand même qu'il a été le
dernier arrivé sur place qu'il a été le
premier à repartir en jet privé
ce fameux bouquin qui parait où elle
écrivait toutes ces journal intime
est-ce que on va pouvoir un jour savoir
comme les dossiers déclassement elle a
donné des ordres elle a donné des ordres
à ce qu'ils soient que même son fils je
crois ne pourra pas avoir accès avant 50
ans et en 50 ans il a 75 ans il a 74
bleu pour écrire son journal intime
alors que toute le reste de la
correspondance était écrit
très très touchante celle-là elle fait
le tour du monde un peu comme Diana sur
son bateau regardez cette image où elle
est seule parce qu'il y a le covid
moi ça m'avait bouleversé cette image
son mari qu'elle aimait et on oublie de
le dire un peu parce que pardon on tombe
souvent sur les Macron où on dit qu'il
avait 16 ans et qu'elle était plus âgé
quand elle raconte son mari elle a 13
ans c'est un coup de foudre incroyable
enfin ça va elle est tombée tout de
suite vous êtes pervers ici rien tu
étais dans la chambre toi mais pas du
tout il faisait l'armée idiot et donc
restituer les choses dans la génération
de la reine à cette époque là on avait
un mari on couchait une fois qu'on était
marié
[Applaudissements]
ce qui est beau c'est que elle va la
poser Philippe parce que certes il est
prince de graisse et de Danemark mais il
est désargenté il est fauché comme les
blés personne n'en veut pas aller il
arrive avec une valise en carton elle va
anoblir elle va l'enrichir elle est à
l'époque le parti de plus bonne Cabal du
du globe Elisabeth 2h et elle est
follement amoureuse c'est elle qui est
amoureuse lui fait davantage en mariage
de raison ce qui est intéressant c'est
ce qui va se passer parce que vous
parliez de Mégane pour eux Mégane et
Harry là ça va être là là ils vont des
chanter parce que oui maintenant a dit
c'est pas compliqué alors déjà
j'habiterai publique une gamme ça sera
ouvert au public six mois par an ça sera
que pour les banques à d'État et moi je
vais rester il va faire une monarchie
centralala sans faible tous les gens qui
vivent à Kensington qui est un deuxième
palais là où habitait d'ailleurs Harry
et Meghan quand ils étaient mariés et
William et Kate en fait tous les cousins
qui sont nourris gratuitement nous
nourri
et arrive à lui dire maintenant mon
petit chou maintenant tu travailles
terminé
24 milliards la famille en fait total en
fait c'est difficile
que dans le coffre-fort de la reine elle
s’intéressait pas beaucoup aux oeuvres
d'art il y a la plus grande collection
Léonard de Vinci on estime oui mais
c'est ça qui est difficile
du public
dernière image parce qu'il peut regarder
c'est avec l'espace girls si on peut la
montrer parce qu'il paraît que d'abord
les mets la musique mais qu'elle était
très drôle très drôle dans le privé très
patient rire c'est vrai ça ouais imiter
les gens et elle adorait à faire avec
ses petits-enfants faire des imitations
et raconter en privé qui a demandé à
rencontrer justement les Spice Girls à
l'époque c'était en 97 où elles
explosaient l'espace girl il a dit
j'aimerais bien les rencontrer et elle
adore la mode si c'était une icône
fashion enfin tu me coupes si j'ai aussi
j'adore mais elle était avec une des
stylistes anglaises les plus en vue qui
s'appelle Angela Kelly qui est une nana
incroyable qui est très pote avec Ana
Wintour etc elle a été plusieurs fois
dans le Vogue aussi UK la reine
d'Angleterre et elle adorait la mode
elle aimait le bleu je crois c'est sa
couleur préférée est-ce qu'il y a marqué
aussi les gens c'est la cérémonie
d'ouverture des JO quand même où elle le
fait elle simule
c'est un moment
si vous aimez la reine et ben discuter
avec nous c'est un documentaire inédit
les 70 ans de son couronnement vous
allez tout apprendre justement sur la
reine c'est secret tout ce qu'elle
aimait ce qu'elle aimait pas c'est tout
de suite sur C8 merci à tous d'avoir été
avec nous